"Is my only option to do it on my own?"
So I have a great question from one of my YouTube viewers, Jeremy, who wrote in to say:
"Hello, Evan! Great video, as always! You're my favorite guru!" Thanks, Jeremy...
"I need help, I have an idea for recording a short drama/music video, but I don't know anyone
"reliable enough who has the creativity or understanding to help me shoot the video
and I don't have the funds to hire a professional videographer or crew."
"What can I do? Is my only option to do it all on my own?"
Jeremy...
welcome to the world of entrepreneurship! Right?
We NEVER have the resources we need to make our vision happen.
And entrepreneurs, the difference... what makes a successful entrepreneur is you find a way.
You find a way to bootstrap this thing up and make your dream happen
when all logical things say: "this is never going to happen." Ok?
So here are some options for you. You want to make this video happen?
Here are a few options you can try:
First off: Get a clear vision.
Ok? I would research other videos, other productions that you've looked at, that you like,
and try to identify the elements of those videos that you really like. Right?
There's tons of videos online, go to YouTube, start your search.
Pull out elements and make a list. Let's say: "You know? From 10 seconds to 20 seconds
I really like how they do this..." So the more specific you can get, the better.
Second thing is: Go out and start networking with people who believe in the same thing as you.
I don't know what this video's all about, right?
You need to do a good job with explaining the big vision behind it.
Why are you doing this? Why is it so important to you? What big thing are you trying to accomplish?
Because if your video stands for something that has meaning, that is going to have an impact on this world,
then people will want to be a part of it, but you have to explain what you're doing.
So, for example, I like to salsa dance, ok? And recently, this morning, a salsa band wrote to me,
they're launching a new song and they're bringing in people from around the world
and they're asking them: "can you please dance on camera to all or part of the song?
"Because we want to make a music video combining all the dancers from around the world with our song."
So it's a pretty cool project and it's a nice song, so I'm thinking of going with my dance partner to Toronto Island
so I can film the CN Tower behind and I'll dance to the song and hopefully be part of their video.
Why am I doing this? I'm doing this for free, right? I've got to take time to go to Toronto Island,
travel there, come up with, you know, whatever I'm going to dance to; it's going to take like the whole
day to do this. Why am I willing do to this?!
Because it's fun. Because it's different. Because it's going to have an impact.
And it's free, right? I'm not getting paid to do this.
So, people will join your cause if they feel like they're doing something important; so, explain it. Right?
And start hanging around people, networking online, offline;
with people who can potentially help you in the video space. Ok?
Number 3, though, is: Don't let the lack of a video editor hold you back.
Get started.
Because too many times entrepreneurs are launching a product and they say:
"Oh, I finally have this and I can make it", or "until I get the funding", or "until I get the partner",
or "until I get the sponsorship, I'm not going to do anything."
That's not how it works!
You've got to start creating momentum. You've got to start building this thing up.
And it may mean you do the whole thing yourself,
but start! Don't let the lack of resources or capital, or people, or ideas hold you back
from getting this thing done. Because this is only one project, man.
You've got a long future ahead of you, of great things. This is one project to kick you off.
So 1: research, do your homework; background, find all the elements that you love that you want to include.
2: make this thing important. Start hanging out and introducing it to people who
are in the video space, who may be able to help you out.
And then 3: just get started. Do something every day to make this thing go a little bit further
and don't let the lack of anything hold you back, because what entrepreneurs are great at is turning nothing,
turning an idea, into something special.This is your first challenge.
Believe!
For those of you watching, I'd love to hear what you have to think.
How did you find the people, the resources to make your first idea happen?
Leave it in the comment section below. I'm curious to learn and it's also going to help inspire other people,
so leave it below.
You liked this video? Give it a thumbs up, it makes me want to do more for you.
And click on my face to subscribe to the channel to see more videos like this.
Thank you so much! I'll see you soon.
Subtitles by the Amara.org community